climate research health and young people  are all priorities for the european  parliament in the 2021-2027 eu budget  without research programs like horizon  europe and funding from eu for health  the eu will not remain a world leader in  the search for vaccines and treatments  without the just transition fund  european regions that depend on carbon  energy  risk being left behind as we move to a  climate neutral europe  without erasmus plus millions of young  people will not have opportunities to  learn  train and exchange without digital  europe the eu will not be at the cutting  edge of developing artificial  intelligence  cyber security and digital technologies  parliament rejects cuts to these  programs which are crucial in investing  in a better  fairer and greener future for europeans